Rig logic and the metahuman face and body animation blueprints have a variety of functions.
Let's begin by answering the question, what is rig logic?
Rig logic is a runtime facial rig evaluation solver system developed by 3Lateral and it
relies on a universal set of rules for defining the muscular system of a human face.
For rig logic to work, it needs metahuman DNA, a proprietary file format that stores
the complete description of a metahuman's face rig and geometry.
Some important elements that make up the metahuman face rig include joint, skin weight, and blend
shape deformers, base and animated texture maps setups, the rig logic plugin and metahuman
DNA, the user interface of the face control rig, and built in LODs.
Simply put, rig logic allows for animations to be shared by all metahumans and LODs.
And it is responsible for activating blend shapes, corrective blend shapes, and joint
transformations while triggering animated maps during animation.
Let's jump into Unreal Engine for a moment to take a closer look at these animated maps
and see how they are activated by rig logic.
Inside of the metahuman blueprint, let's begin by selecting the face component.
Over here in the details panel, let's open up the head synthesized material instance.
Inside of here, we have a variety of parameters we can adjust.
The base color texture maps are located over here.
We have the main albedo texture, and then right below we have three blood flow maps.
If we open these blood flow maps up, we will see a bit of redness added to certain areas
of the face.
When the face muscles contract during certain expressions, causing the skin to wrinkle in
those areas, the blood flow is pushed towards the edge of the skin.
Each of these blood flow maps are triggered by specific facial poses.
Let's go back to the material instance.
Over here are the normal maps.
We have our main normal map, which is 8K for cinematic metahumans.
And right below are three animated wrinkle maps.
These normal maps work together with the blood flow maps and are set up in the same way so
that when certain muscles are activated for specific facial poses, wrinkles will appear
in those areas.
Rig logic activates all of these textures while also triggering blend shapes, corrective blend
shapes, and joint transforms.
To better see how these texture maps are set up to be triggered by Rig logic, let's scroll
to the bottom of this material instance, and then double click on this, and then double
click on this.
This will open up the M-head baked material.
This is the master material where everything is brought together and connected.
If we look at this section over here, where the normal maps are set up, we will see several
material functions.
If I double click on this material function, we will see more material functions.
And if we open up this material function, inside of here, we can see how some of the
animated wrinkle maps are set up to be triggered by specific facial expressions.
And all of these are activated and evaluated through the face post-process animation blueprint.
Now, before we move on, let's do a quick review of what we just covered.
The face component has materials that use animated wrinkle maps.
Rig logic is responsible for triggering when the face is animated.
The M-head baked material is the master material that contains several material functions set
up to trigger the different texture maps for specific facial poses.
One of the benefits of the way this is all set up is that you can use the existing blood
flow and normal wrinkle maps as a base for customizing your own textures, and then easily
replace the existing ones with yours in the head synthesized material instance.
The rig logic node lives in the face post-process animation blueprint.
If the blueprint is disabled, it will only trigger joint deformations, resulting in a
boost in performance but at the expense of quality.
The images on the right are examples of what a smile looks like when the face post-process
is enabled and disabled.
With complex expressions, some joints are affected by more than one expression, resulting
in multiplied deformations.
Corrective blend shapes on the metahuman face have been defined to correct the joint overlap
for complex expressions such as the smile.
The face post-process blueprint is also where the neck correctives for the head component
are set up.
The animated gif all the way on the right shows these at work.
When the neck moves, the volume in these areas of deformation are preserved so that it looks
natural.
When disabled, we will see a boost in performance but at the expense of quality.
The body animation blueprint contains corrective poses through a pose driver setup.
These trigger specific combinations of poses and joints that correct certain skeleton poses.
We can see these corrective poses at work in the animated gif on the left.
When the upper arm is rotated, the volume is preserved by these corrective poses.
Using the pose driver connect tool set in Autodesk Maya, you can author your own corrective
poses and import those into Unreal Engine.
And we touch on this in the metahuman DNA calibration courses.
There are cases where individual body correctives can be adjusted when retargeting animations
from skeletons that have different proportions.
So let's jump into Unreal Engine for a moment to take a look at this process.
Inside of the animation sequence window, I have applied an animation to Lena's skeletal
mesh.
I'm going to bring the upper arms closer to view so that we can see the changes that
will occur once we make some adjustments to the skeleton retargeting options of the correctives.
In the skeleton tree panel on the left, I'm going to go to the cogwheel and select show
retargeting options.
For the main joints such as the spines, the upper and lower arms, and so on, I have changed
the retargeting options for those to skeleton and left all of the correctives set to animation.
If we search for the upper arm in the skeleton tree search bar, the upper arm joints will
be displayed.
This here is one of the many correctives for the left upper arm.
And these down here are correctives for the right upper arm.
If I select all of the correctives for the left upper arm and right click on them and
select recursively set translation retargeting to skeleton, the volume in the upper arm area
will be lost.
Using this setting is helpful for the main joints when retargeting animations from different
skeletons and skeletons of different proportions.
Now if I right click and select recursively set translation retargeting to animation,
we can see the volume returns.
Before we move on, let's do a quick review of the steps we just covered.
We just went through an example showing how we can adjust the bone translation retargeting
options settings for the body correctives.
By changing the retargeting options for the main joints to skeleton, this takes differences
in skeleton proportions out of the equation so that animations can be applied to different
skeletons.
Leaving the correctives to animation preserves the volume in areas of deformation regardless
of differences in skeleton proportions.
To do this, in the skeleton tree, go to the cogwheel and check on show retargeting options.
From there you can either change the translation retargeting of individual joints, or select
a group of joints, then right click and select recursively set to and choose either skeleton,
animation, animation scaled and so on.
The bone retargeting options are helpful when retargeting and applying animation data from
skeletons of different proportions.
Now let's move on to the next section of our course where we explore a few different ways
we can animate metahumans.